[Music]
good morning guys
what up vlog Monday morning Jets game
devastating emotions running high never
wanted to care this year don't know how
I got suckered in classic Jets and the
year that I was thrilled to go home in
16 and be passive they suckered me in to
break my [ __ ] heart yesterday it's so
little energy this Monday morning a
bunch of business reviews going out to
Long Island doing a talk coming back
doing a wine dinner with a bunch of
people think we should film a lot of
that did we get the approval on that
that's gonna be really rad I'm sure
you're about to watch that but the 90
day business reviews with all the
offices and divisions at Vayner so
really heads down grinding work well
show you some b-roll in that working on
a lot of the sneaker stuff the Gary Vee
o 1 and O twos are coming I'm super
excited about that let's go what's up
guys happy Monday hope everybody super
well fun news putting a new sign on the
Wine Library big-ass sign on the
building you've seen it before we've got
it updated and so I'm looking for sign
purveyors if you are a company that
sells signage that goes on buildings I'd
like to hear from you Gary at
vaynermedia comm I would like to give
you some business looking for the best
service and the best deals
keeping it simple let's do this good
luck pass it on to your sign buddies the
number one skill to have in
communication is the ability to listen
once you deploy empathy and listening
skills you know what to say this is the
biggest miss by 99.9% of the market
[Music]
two hardcore reviews I'm sure iris did
some cool time-lapse and some rad music
now headed to Long Island for an event
I'm gonna catch up on phone calls would
you stop going on there good day so far
solid solid amount of work done in the
first couple hours a day thank you
brother thank you brother appreciate it
spicies [ __ ] but I'm too mentally strong
flavor
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're getting here let's get
in here see what's going on here let's
go way back when I did a talk for
Daymond John one of his buddies asked me
to do it talk to us at his conference I
said yes we're gonna go give a talk at
this conference now we'll see what this
is all about looking forward to it but
it breaks other people's opinions by
telling your mom to go [ __ ] themselves
Bryce I'm so hot on this man I am so sad
that the reason you get a reaction like
that is a mix between it's funny to use
the word mom and [ __ ] in the same
sentence right but but it's way more
true if you listen to the tone of the
laughs in there and saw what I just saw
the truth in what I just said is so
powerful I am so sorry
first I am driven by gratitude I'm
grateful that my parents were so awesome
they never made me feel inferior right
and so many of you whether through a
sibling or a parent had a miserable sad
negative parent who tried to impose
their negativity on you and misery loves
company and its greatest execution as
parents on kids there's something we
never talk about it's not talked about
enough and so if my legacy when I die
when I take my last breath if you asked
me what I really think I'm gonna think I
think I'm gonna think that I was the
human being that came along and brought
the most awareness to this conversation
it is my absolute passion because I've
seen what my grandma did to my dad and I
know what my mom did to me and it's a
big [ __ ] difference bro
it's called happiness so why do I think
a lot of you don't do [ __ ] because you
just you other people's opinions of you
why do I think you have that because you
weren't given self esteem as a kid and
you were gone the other way and if
there's anything one of the biggest
reasons I act like a big-shot is because
I want kids to become fans of me so that
I can then become the shield for them to
have confidence to do good things not
bad things because if I'm cool then
they're not talking about Ferraris and
[ __ ] gold watches they're talking
about hardwork humility empathy and
kindness
[Music]
thank you oh now it smells down here 60
seconds on a white people can't really
get past their fuse my big thing is that
people's fears are predicated on other
people right so they are allowing other
people's opinions you're allowing other
people's opinions to dictate your life
the fear is being judged right it's just
classic high school peer pressure you
actually care about what your dad or mom
or grandma or husband or wife or
daughter or son is gonna say about you
if you do this thing which I'm very
empathetic I care so much about those
people in my life but I will not allow
them to dictate my behavior because
ultimately I don't want to be mad at
them or really have this pent-up
resentment so many of you are gonna be
resentful and blame somebody else
besides yourself it's your fault that
you know you're not doing your thing and
so the reason I think it's happening is
the judgment of others it's the same
[ __ ] from fourth and fifth grade that we
develop and a lot of it has to do with
the parents that you had and so I
implore everybody to understand you only
have one life and it's much better to
live it for yourself than somebody else
400 trillion to one that's it baby
appreciate it take care of Oh bye talk
is done I've got some good content in
there I'm super excited about it see ya
hey guys some breaking news out of the
tech world looks like Facebook just
acquired tbh which has been a an app
that is a positive focused polling app
that I've been noticing ranking very
high on the App Store here in a
TechCrunch article they're saying tbh
has scored five million downloads and
2.5 million daily daily daily active
users in the past nine weeks and it's an
app that allows people to answer kind
hearted multiple-choice questions about
friends positivity on the offense kind
of the reverse of what we saw from
secret and whisper anonymous negative
which is what you normally get they
created restrictions that made an
anonymous positive but the biggest
reason I'm jumping in here and I've said
it and listen I have great ambition to
be known as an all-time great day trader
of attention right but nobody in the
corporate world today does a better job
on paying attention to attention better
than Mark Zuckerberg in the team at
Facebook whether it was their
acquisition of Instagram or even going
back to friend friend finder and what
was it that they bought Taylor not
friends River and fire maybe a friend
find Jesus I can't remember but going
back to all their acquisitions obviously
Instagram obviously their bid on
snapchat FriendFeed unfriend feed I
remember that look I got it I think it's
from people will say anyway nonetheless
thanks iris so much more fun a virus
here than P Rock babbit I love anyway
nonetheless FriendFeed I think is right
actually - - which is more talent and
infrastructure but attention whether
it's been Instagram or snapchat the way
they think or whatsapp or the way they
think about VR and oculus I'm just
obsessed with their ability to do so and
now another purchase from the Facebook
family over it and I love hard tbh
they're gonna let it run by itself the
article says I mean read the article
just want to get my first quick take
want to definitely do some more breaking
news quick takes what does this mean it
means one thing that sucks and Cheryl
and the rest of the Facebook mafia does
it better than anybody in arbitrage
inattention sometimes they'll miss
sometimes the win but they're always
gonna play in buying up attention as a
platform I try to trade it as a creative
and as a media player
and as a personality I see what they're
doing and I like it
[Music]
I'm gonna like just stick your P
locations let's go do you have the other
pair the office I can shoot them on a
model though and composite them onto
your feet Oh [ __ ] knew it
like we are so bad at dumb [ __ ] it's
unbelievable huh
it's let's go ahead let's let me
literally said my piece so we're
shooting my new case with sneakers
I'm fab and literally forgot the
sneakers at the office this morning I
don't know if we caught it iris I don't
think so
so before you started filming uh I told
Tyler for me to like like literally like
give him you give him toffee and be like
we heat we got it we got it and
literally right now when I was like
where the other pair he's like I forgot
him at the office I literally was like I
[ __ ] knew it and let me tell you why
vaynernation
I knew it because we are unbelievable
unbelievable all the hardship right like
everyone's like so stunned by our
ability to do so much [ __ ] that we do
but we suck [ __ ] at the most basic [ __ ]
like bringing the [ __ ] sneakers to
the shoot for the shoot of the [ __ ]
sneakers you're shooting my sneakers and
you forgot the sneakers Thank You iris
for the proper for the proper reaction
I'm really the four people that like me
more than beer I've just looked yeah
like I've literally been working the
last month to get you six fans and now
back to [ __ ] zero I'm not shooting
with these I'm just like I'm like I'm
like I'm upset I'm not uh I'm not doing
it we'll have to figure out tomorrow
you ever hear to the term cut your nose
to spite your face that was the example
babban
that was cool
now Tyler's not picking it up okay is
that why you're hanging up nice to meet
you
nice to meet you are you very good good
he's helped all along to mother Logan
yeah Gary nice to meet you nice
he's jumping on a lot of Boehner sports
stuff done a lot of video stuff for the
athletes thank you real pleasure oh the
dude a Florida dude yeah some answers
nice to meet you I appreciate that
awesome real pleasure how are things
good for some in the city so it's been
really cool so what the plan was like I
was like we're doing a photo
babban has totally [ __ ] up this entire
episode of Daily Mail at least we got to
meet absolutely you want a job I've
gotten one short on my video I got it I
got a do a call nice to meet you man it
would have been good if you figured it
out 19 minutes ago instead of iris
please make sure you're filming all this
like don't get caught don't yeah you
gotta be yes good afternoon how you
doing
[Music]
a vlog I'm doing my one antisocial move
usually before events I'm just trying to
get my last minute work into it and so
that's what I'm doing
[Music]
thank you thank you so much brother
so happier here and I'll do all this
other [ __ ] damn when I was a kid I'm
looking at these guys no 42 year old you
know I mean I'm a signature shoe come
out thank you that's not how we grew up
like a businessman was a student you
know you were it's great I mean I'm cool
right 42 that I was at 24 and it's not
even [ __ ] close it's crazy it speaks
the truth but it wasn't that truth in it
it did it because it wasn't a truth yet
because the seat of hip-hop hip-hop
hidden scale yeah there was a baby you
know what it would be you know what it
is it's you and I probably if we were 20
years older would have been rock and
roll kick yeah because that's what it
represented right that's all I just like
our thing better I'm really glad that
it's that inclusive than that like
authentic it it's cool yeah I totally
agree with you it's wild to watch when
you go on stage though I look like you
have almost like God I actually use this
example talking about you people and I
feel like it's like watching like DMC at
the garden and the game sticks like when
you come on stage or you don't come on
like killer
I'm completely affected by those acts
and Richard Pryor and Betty Murph like
I'm completely affected by
you know early hip-hop acts [ __ ] with me
because it wasn't that entertaining
first like it's still rap is funny that
way yeah like it's not like I've always
was more about like oh they [ __ ] to
your point to kill it and there's words
what they meant right the entertainment
value is a little more difficult like
your guy in the back is like yeah yeah
like it's a funny little big I think
you're right do you think one thing I'm
working on actually curious what you
think about it is I'm creating this
constant series where I'm actually going
and talking to like CEOs and PMO's the
EC's about how hip-hop inspire them and
their successful business I think it's a
few listen you've probably heard it cuz
I know you see some of my stuff I think
hip-hop is the foundation of our I think
that's exactly you should a hundred
percent like the perfect guy to do that
because I'm real extraño on that when
you're done with it come and come and
see me we haven't hung out in a while
let me look at it and give you some
sense would you be down to talk further
energy thrills we just talked about rap
we should spend more time together you
have a great team of people working with
you now thank you mother
so basically here's what I did i
decanted four of each of these okay at
11 o'clock love it
I began did this one at 11 o'clock but
these but I brought extras of these but
we're not to camp at 11 o'clock so they
can pop these because we'll have them to
get all the minutes and all the very
complex way that they drew from four
different spots in the armitage for that
so anyways you get to the crackers and
the softest things up a little bit
[Music]
so basically went out what I did was I
brought stuff to campus at 11:00 and I
brought stuff that hasn't been opened
yet so I figure we duel I'm excited by
some just give him a little variance of
what they'll learn what do you think of
the what do you think of all right I'm a
huge [ __ ] fan of their minds for a
long time you know this is Joe Lee this
is uh I had him on Wine Library TV oh
you did was the best interview I've ever
had no I love him here's a whack job of
the rack [ __ ] job it was supposed to
be 15 20 minutes it was an hour and 13
minutes I'll never forget I missed my I
didn't even go to the city for a tasting
I was supposed to go to because we had
such a great time I mean I'm gonna show
this guy stuff it's gonna be interesting
scary very to see what they are how they
react to it how are you Gary
cool stuff so this guy I began to moan
oil I did the kantham in 11 because I
didn't mean to get rid of some of that
Jareau style chicken yeah how much
revenue okay yeah this is [ __ ]
gangster which crazy about this is so
it's so crazy so fun to get back into
the wine brother we did this I mean
what's going on on Instagram right now
is I would argue grossly underestimated
by the majority of us maybe including me
who spends eight hours a day trying to
figure it out we've got culture living
through this platform at a scale that I
think makes people I just don't think
people understand what's actually
happening which is the amount of actual
net attention on this platform speaks to
a time where a lot of looking around the
room a lot of us grew up when there was
less channels you know when you know yo
MTV raps looking around the room knowing
a lot of people in the room so impactful
right why kiddin medicine
New Jersey that like was the prop again
I needed to get into the culture I just
I just think Instagram is stunningly
underestimated did you see what he did
today the guide trades attention
he bought tbh today like all he does
every behavior out of his out of his
actions is buying and trading attention
totally does I met him in 2008 it's this
kids app that is do you remember secret
and whisper anonymous Yik yak all these
viral apps the reason they all failed is
when you were anonymous the lowest
common denominator of human behavior
kicks in and it's really fun to say
something anonymous about your neighbor
until somebody says something about you
and then everybody leaves tbh went the
other way it was anonymous but it was
forced positivity so you would do a poll
and like little things about people but
you had to say something good which
created virality because people liked
hearing nice things about themselves
from anonymous sources became huge with
teenagers it's a number six app in the
App Store right now loved him so much
responsible for me being me today and I
really appreciate him and being here
tonight I thank you thanks brother I got
a run please
reach out Robert and I are now heading
to Harlem because that's how we do we're
gonna do a little bit of a chef little
uh Marcus Santos in a little Harlem
action Robert yeah Marcus Hamilton he's
been involved food and wine always like
listen I can't come to your amazing
dinner but you gotta come to mind I've
never met anybody but I wasn't even here
to go like love you we know a lot of
connectors like we're all living life
the amount of connectors who don't have
intent to trade on the connection in the
short term barely exist and that's and
that's why I appreciate this
[Music]
hey guys wrapping up gonna send an iris
home because it's uh it's late already
it's ten o'clock and we've got two hours
here at the Red Rooster a bunch of
people from food and wine gonna see some
old friends do some networking you know
no matter where you get to you've always
got to do a little hunting a little
farming a little networking a little
shaking hands a little kissing babies
just a very grateful for the life I'm
living and more importantly for the
attention that you guys give me and so I
hope you have a wonderful day
iris to the great job that was a good
day see you guys later
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]